welcome to this video playing satellite
from Canada and that that's what you get
for playing Knight f6 the Trump hmm what
to play against the troll
I usually play a c6 year but i don't
really like the position that i that i
get from that this is supposed to be a
solid alternative yeah this is a
possibility this this gambit line but
black can also um just develop normally
like and I'm trying to do here I don't
think this should be too bad it's a bit
similar looking this position on but
similarly looking like the fantasy
variation of the kernel corn and now it
looks like a french exchange hmm okay
how to how to develop him the question
is okay let's just if i play see 5 or
not this is the question and i played c5
very often this is just the right
reaction to to f3 open up the position
and try to do something on the dark
squares because these sell weekend so it
looks like I'm nicely centralized here
shouldn't be a two bed two better
position k is canceling long
Queen p6 yeah let's do that a5 was
designed to play a 4 and so on too yeah
like this to provoke some sort of
weakness what now we should be six
probably it's a bit unfortunate that i'm
in a pin here the loop here maybe it may
be just that one protecting d5 at
allowing and move by this night
hmm Gerald f6 so not great this move but
ok maybe Bishop f7 is a useful square
and now what no 94 something like that
on or porn D for even ponder for we're
not actually
now we should be four oh this is nice
he's in an awkward penny I didn't see
this before you just should win the
exchange c3 and just take
getting Bishop a 2-1 moves like that in
the mix
it's just a cheque SI 2 o 3 36 just
simple chess Queenie 6 threatening
threatening on a two how does he
prevented
we are only needs to play b 3 which is
not quite a quite grade I'm going to sac
then on on somewhere I don't see it si
tu it's probably not a win
okay keep it simple come on and just and
just this one this should be simple at
good exchanging the bishop it'sit's
after all it's just an exchange
if he takes rook takes I have an active
route also Quincy six is a threat yeah I
think this was this was a good practical
decision just back back here
and maybe all the way back not sure but
just rook c8 is this right now hard for
him to to keep it do I can just take
right
Oh what this should be should both be
good Luke takes
I can take the form
check
just Roxy too
threatened hmm
sure
yeah 35 seconds I still managed to to
make make it some more interesting
really bad
24 now my on earth is this game still
going
yeah I must have missed something
something easy probably it's not a queen
dee 5
ok
96 I can probably go to g6
check
time warning
check
huh
check
check
check
check
check check check
now I can play oops black4 fits on time
we do a 00 yeah yeah great great play
yeah I really would like to know when I
mr. simple knock out here I mean minus
11 upgrade f5 whatever ok this is also
went I mean it was winning all along I
was just taking too much time for all
this nonsense around here this is a
slightly tricky now of course and with
20 seconds ok yeah f5's minus 7 and so
on but then came I've got 20 seconds
this is a winning end game that ok at
the time yeah yeah yeah I actually
peeled till you plate this fairly well I
mean same
check
yeah here King deforms winning I must
keep the last pawn and this is this is
not just a draw because he gets both
pawns yeah this was tried to win a ton
of course yeah and then bit unlucky to
lose with 000 sometimes it happens it's
on 000 news on time and I was just
taking taking this but quite unlucky
just one hundreds of seconds would would
have been enough otherwise it was them
this was draw all pretty nice for black
well okay thanks for watching